you know me talking about these topics I
really think is helpful to women
um because women we're just confused and
we're confused because of relationship
podcasts like this we're confused
because of the media or be we're
confused because of all the symptoms
that tell us what we want to hear and
you know I really thought I would get a
very nice thank you from the ladies
that's really what I thought I would get
I thought they would say pearl thank you
so much for all of your help Pearl I
appreciate you pointing this out
but no so I recently have had a hate
article made on me can you guys believe
it it says the terrifying rise
of all right female influencers
am I terrifying
oh my gosh
I thought I was a nice lady but I guess
I guess I'm terrifying now
all right they said toxic femininity is
real says a steely-eyed woman dressed in
a black lace top and bright red lipstick
with a red rose tucked behind her ear
the artificial background in her video
thrown with flowers and frilly
lampshades the woman is Daisy cousins
and she's one of the leading lights in
the female alt-right influencer movement
in Australia I've never heard of this
chick but she seems like a cool chick
from what they're saying you know if
they're writing articles she has more
than 200k subscribers on YouTube posting
regular videos with names like why
pretty women should never be feminists
and leftism makes young women miserable
the article delves into the emergence of
Women Within the far right and alt-right
movements
wow am I alt right now shedding light on
their pivotal role in disassemminating
extremist ideologies through digital
platforms and online spaces
am I an extremist
okay okay is it because I said men are
smarter than women or because they said
women shouldn't vote
I actually think these are really
logical opinions I think they're really
logical
am I am I extreme now you know it's the
time period honestly a hundred years ago
I would have just been a normal lady it
is not my fault I was born in this time
period okay
these women adopt a range of personas
and strategies to Garner attention often
portraying themselves as conservatives
traditionalists or proponents of the
Trad wife concept
prominent figures in this domain
includes Daisy cousins
I should reach out she seems like a nice
lady Pearl Davis Lena lock tough never
heard her oh my girl Laura Loomer
Laura Loomer I we I tweeted her
sometimes you know
wow
so are they're calling me a prominent
figure
this is amazing
and they're saying I'm all right now wow
all right women active in these
movements hold a spectrum of viewpoints
spanning from conservative to extremists
where do you think they have me
what about when I said women are useless
okay I didn't say that till now
um their Adept use of online platforms
allow them to tackle issues like
feminism immigration transgender rights
and vaccination in ways that package
their message is more approachable and
appealing
I actually think this article has kind
of giving me a big head
did you hear that approachable
appealing
the article suggests that women are
effective in rendering extremist
ideologies more acceptable and
mainstream
ah
so I'm mainstream now
wow effectively enticing individuals
into their belief systems using a softer
approach
so I'm soft
you know
stop it stop it you guys are so nice
The Surge of participating in Far Right
scene reflects a response to the
evolving dynamics of society where
social media wields significant
influence in amplifying and radicalizing
perspectives by capitalizing on the
online environment these women can
propagate content that aligns with
far-right ideologies
potentially leading susceptible
individuals to embrace those
perspectives
so they're calling me persuasive
this is amazing I'm having so
I hope they write more articles on me a
phenomenon often referred to as red
pilling the article
the article also delves into the Trad
wife movement which Champions for
traditional gender roles and frequently
covers covers far-right ideologies you
know what's funny I was thinking about
this where they're like Pearl you just
tell everyone to get married and I'm
like
I think I tell people not to get married
more than I pushed marriage
and recently I was thinking they're like
well Pearl you shouldn't start a gender
War
and I'm thinking why not really they're
just asking for women to be able to say
whatever they want and have no
consequence because there's been a
gender war on men for at least 50 years
and all of you guys were quiet but the
second were like all right let's
criticize women a little bit
now it's a gender War
how convenient how convenient is that
it's like
okay sorry
um
but yeah so that's why I was like you
know if anything it's really just
self-defense at this point from the man
this article also delves into the Chad
my wife movement which Champions
traditional gender roles and frequently
covers far-right ideologies some
adherence of this movement advocate for
anti-feminism
homophobia
and transphobia employing their
conservative values as a platform to
challenge contemporary societal Norms
experts Express apprehension about the
political impact of female influencers
and advancing far-right agendas while
social media platforms have made
attempts to curb the dissemination of
extremist content these Endeavors aren't
always successful as alternative
platforms and communication methods
persist okay now they're set now they're
saying
that the all the company should ban us
and if they don't ban us
now they're whining about our about
Rumble really
law enforcement faces complexities in
addressing these challenges in
conclusion these articles accentuates
the mounting involvement of Women Within
the far-right and alt-right circles
particularly in the digital realm these
women employ diverse tactics to
propagate extremist ideologies and
persist a more engaging facade to lure
followers this trend underscores the
necessity for sustained vigilance and
awareness regarding the heterogeneous
array of individuals contributing to the
extremist movement well guys
I took that as a compliment so number
one they called me mainstream you know
number two they said I'm persuasive
number three they said I'm warm and soft
thank you Marie Claire thank you very
much that was a very nice article you
wrote